wife killer dr krippen in the dock of
the old bailey's court number one
this snatched photo led to a ban on
cameras in all criminal courts until now
112 years on tv cameras will be allowed
in to record just a small part the very
end of some high-profile cases
for the first time viewers will see
trial judges handing down sentences
and explaining their decisions
the move is for transparency in courts
there are only a few seats for the
public
many more will see justice being done
but they won't see the defendants
victims witnesses or lawyers open
justice is important
and sentencing of serious criminal cases
is something in which there is a
legitimate public interest
and it's always seemed to me that this
is a part of the criminal process
which can be
recorded and broadcast
the old bailly has had many sensational
cases
serial killer the yorkshire ripper the
cray gangster twins ruth ellis the last
woman in britain to be hanged until now
for the grim details the public largely
has had to rely on court reporters i've
probably trodden every part of this
courtroom except one and that's the bit
we're not allowed to show you
i've never stood as a prisoner in the
dock but i know a man who has
jonathan aitken is a priest and prison
chaplain before that he was a cabinet
minister jailed for lying in a libel
trial i certainly felt very bad indeed
when i was being sentenced and i guess
i'd have felt even worse if i'd known it
was being televised but on the other
hand
why shouldn't it make it feel worse i
mean the crime has been done the guilt
has been proved the sentence is coming
that is justice being done openly and as
visibly as possible which i think is
absolutely right the court can certainly
declare that the advice was unlawful
some years ago cameras were allowed
first into the supreme court then the
court of appeal
now cameras in criminal courts after a
campaign led by the main news
broadcasters this is a really
significant moment
for
the uh opening up our of our courts in
england and wales it's a further step
towards the transparency of a really
serious institution the judicial system
in america some criminal trials are
broadcast in full and often in painful
detail
[Music]
is such tv coverage likely here one day
my own but fairly strong view
is that what we see happening around the
world
illustrates why that can be quite
damaging
for now cameras here will be focused
purely on the judge
and the sentence